bonjour mesdames et messieurs non
commençons le travail dans le cadre de
la dernière session de la 9e conférence
de moscou sur la sécurité internationale
avec les sujets proposés et qui est
toujours présent par tradition sur
l'agenda du forum de moscou c'est la
sécurité européen et c'est pas par
hasard du tout parce que pour la
sécurité de la fédération de russie
il est extrêmement important de suivre
l'état sur ses frontières
l'or au cours de l'inauguration de la
conférence air a réalisé par le général
d'armée sergueï choïgou mission de
défendre la fédération de russie et
messieurs guerassimova les chefs
d'etat-major général de la fédération de
russie ils ont déjà détaillé la
situation sur les frontières de la
russie et sinon dressons le bilan
brièvement dans l'ensemble d'après
l'estimation du ministère de la défense
russe
la situation en europe a actuellement
est explosive parce que nous voyons le
renforcement de la présence de l'otan''
est sûre les frontière occidentale de la
russie
la shell et le nombre des détournements
augmentée qui résulte en augmentation
des incidents et provocation avec et des
conséquences imprévisibles dont les
exemples ont été cités par le chef
d'état major général qui était lié avec
les activités de la marine britannique
et américaine dans les eaux
territoriales de la fédération de russie
est un parent du clae y est
à la grande opinion publique a pris
encore en cas de cet incident ou le
distributeur britannique des fender n'a
pas respecté les eaux territoriales à
côté de la crimée en plus d'après les
médias britanniques ça a été fait exprès
pour démontrer la présence de la marine
britannique dans la mer noire évidemment
l'estimation de ses activités de la
marine britannique a été déjà donné par
notre ministère de la défense aussi bien
que d'autres ministères nous à fait
étrangère qui avait invité le
représentant de leur ministère de
défense britannique est et c'était une
situation a été estimée comme
provocation dangereuse et j'aimerais
souligner que de la part des mails
étaient russes et l'équipage air du
bâtiment et de l'avion russe
ils ont respecté toutes les standards et
toutes les procédures prévues pour les
cas similaires afin de prévenir les
incidents sur la mer et j'aimerais
attirer votre attention sur le fait que
l'incident a été provoqué par la partie
britannique avec laquelle la fédération
de russie un accord bilatéral et sur la
prévention des incidents sur la mer qui
a été récemment mise à jour qui précise
les modalités d'action des équipages à
pour prévenir l'apparition des
situations dangereuses de ce type
et dans ce contexte nous pensons qu'il
faut entreprendre d'autres pas si
ultérieure afin de prévenir la
répétition des situations similaires et
de reprendre revenir au dialogue
mutuellement respectueux et et comment
le ministre de la défense russe
nous sommes prêts surtout par la voie
militaire
mêmes et il est extrêmement important de
comprendre ce que nos partenaires
pensent à propos de ce sujet et qui sont
les mesures à prendre en commun pour
assurer la désescalade y répondre ce
dialogue
évidemment cette mission touche
l'activité directe de l'activité de la
défense et vu le carnet pratique
d'autres concurrents j'aimerais
m'adresser au speaker de 20 de ce panel
pour qu'ils puissent et essayer de
répondre dans leurs interventions
quelles sont les formes de coopération
entre les différents ministères de la
défense et aqua vers quoi nous pourrions
aspirer et quand et quel type de
dialogue pour être devenir possible
maintenant j'aimerais m'adresser aux
participants à cette discussion et
j'aimerais vous présenter l'équipe
brillante des experts qui ont accepté de
participer tout d'abord c'est madame
helga schmid
le secrétaire général de l'organisation
sur la sécurité et la coopération en
europe
l'ambassadeur extraordinaire et
plénipotentiaire alexandre grouchko qui
est l'adjoint au ministre des affaires
étrangères de la fédération de russie
l'adjoint au président du gouvernement
parlait le ministre de la défense de la
république est servie messieurs stéphane
chiche monsieur guillaume lagon qui
représente et qui est le chef du
département de la coopération bilatérale
de la direction principale des relations
et nationales et stratégiques et de
ministère des forces armées de la
république française
aujourd'hui par visioconférence depuis
et cinkassé le connais lloret salon le
conseiller militaire du ministre de la
défense de l'art est que plus de
finlande qui participa à ce panel et
j'aimerais vous demander d'afficher
le l'ambassadeur plénipotentiaire de la
fédération de russie qui est aussi leur
opposition permanente de la fédération
de russie auprès de l'union européenne
monsieur vladimir tchijov
j'aimerais remercier tous les
spectateurs d'avoir accepté cette
invitation maintenant j'aimerais passer
elle abat rôle à madame quel gâchis
mythe le ce côté général ait de
l'ambition sur la sécurité et la
coopération en europe qui par son
expérience une diplomate allemand qui a
beaucoup travaillé au sein de l'union
européenne et qui occupa le poste du
secrétaire général de l'essai depuis
l'année dernière merci beaucoup c'est à
vous la parole madame
mesdames et messieurs vos excellences
c'est vrai que cette année cette
rencontre se passe dans des conditions
compliquées penser que la pandémie est
toujours en vigueur dans le monde entier
et nous voyons l'augmentation à
l'intensification des activités
militaires dans différentes parties du
monde et les vérifications s'étonne de
nos outils pour prévenir les conflits
mais malheureusement la pandémie a
beaucoup limité nos possibilités de
notre activité et en même temps nos
approches sont toujours utilisés en ce
qui concerne le contrat le traité sur le
ciel au vert nous avons constaté que le
retrait de certains pays de se traiter
maintenant la mise à jour se trouve au
point zéro point mort malgré le fonds
fait que nous devons interagir dans
l'atmosphère de la transparence et
l'ouverture
nous voyons les activités liées au
développement de l'intelligence
artificielle surtout dans le domaine
militaire qui est déjà mentionnés par
les spectacles précédents à d'autres
plats qui fassions scellement de
dialogue et surtout l'adhérence aux
questions de la sécurité surtout dans le
cas où les tensions ont remonté le faut
toujours poursuivre la coopération pour
trouver de solutions communes pour
résoudre tous ces problèmes ou dans quel
domaine pourrions entreprendre des cas
des pas concrets afin d'intensifier le
dialogue plus étroit
je pense qu'elle pourrait intensifier le
dialogue afin de réduire les risques
je pense que nous devons continuer le
travail dense sur cet axe dont le
premier comme j'ai déjà dit
l'intensification du dialogue a lieu
c'est la seule plateforme inclusive pour
discuter des problèmes de la sécurité
notre région et le sud organise des
échanges d'information hebdomadaire dans
l'atmosphère de confiance et de
certitudes et c'est aussi une plateforme
pour différents prix qui permet de créer
de nouveaux documents en plus le cieux
as des plateformes internationales
indépendantes pour discuter des
problèmes de la sécurité en 2017 ce
dialogue a commencé se forment plus
indépendante il s'agit des plateformes
plus flexible afin de trouver la
compréhension mutuelle dans le domaine
militaire et les idées et les approchant
qui apparaissent aux coups de dialogues
sont peu après développé dans le cadre
d'autres structures nous avons organisé
beaucoup de discussions au sein de la
cee concernant les doctrines militaires
et les opérations organisées mais quand
même elle portait sur une grande large
surtout l'amélioration de transparence
réduction des risques des incidents
maintenant j'aimerais passer à la
deuxième partie si pas de la réduction
des risques qui est toujours très
présent sur notre agenda
parce qu'aujourd'hui niveau de confiance
entre les états est aujourd'hui très bas
et nous avons constaté le haut niveau
d'escaladé et tous les états membres de
lesieu accepte le fait et sont d'accord
sur le fait que cette situation n'est
pas acceptable mais il n'y a pas de
compréhension pourquoi c'est devenu
possible et il n'y a pas de
solution commune parce que différents
états ont des consciences différente par
rapport à la notion de risque et qui
sont les pas qui pourrait nous aider à
développer une approche commune tout
d'abord nous devons consolider des
contacts entre les différents ministères
de la défense sur cet axe elle se
propose aux différents ministères pour
qu'il puisse interagir entre eux
attendent améliorer la confiance comme
par exemple tous les cinq ans nous
organisons des séminaires sur les
doctrines militaires à un haut niveau
par exemple cette année des hauts
fonctionnaires de lesieu et de plusieurs
pays ont discuté des changements dans
les doctrines de leur pays et pour nous
c'est une base pour nous comprendre
ensuite il ya d'autres possibilités
aussi parce que je pense tout d'abord du
travail au sein de comités d'experts l'
échange de visites échanges d'étudiants
entre différence khademi école militaire
la sécu ce type d'activité augmentent le
niveau de confiance écrit un réseau
international des militaires ce qui
favorise la réduction des risques est ce
que nous devons tous les aider
possibilités similaires au maximum
possible
en plus nous devons travailler dans le
but de réduire les risques courants
concrets pour trouver des procédés pour
éviter l' absence de compréhension
il faut toujours finir le travail en
trouvant des compréhension mutuelle par
impression par du document de vienne qui
reflète des possibilités des actions à
entreprendre inquiète dans ses dents et
tous ces options qui sont cités il
pendant le document doit d'être geste
juste mise en plastique on peut regarder
sur une base régulière le nombre de
points de contact ou en cas d'incident
on peut suivre une telle procédure
régulière pour analyser ce qui s'est
passé de fait nous avons un outil clé
faut juste respecter ensuite la
reddition des risques et désescalade
en ce qui concerne les opérations
militaires et les jeux militaires qui
sont réalisés à côté des frontières des
états différents
si nom provient pas l'autre partie ça
pourrait rester un incident pour cette
raison l'amélioration de la confiance
surtout concernant les entraînements et
la proximité des frontières peut réduire
le niveau de méfiance en plus au cours
de la deuxième guerre mondiale nous
avons déjà vieux l'apparition de
nouveaux moyens de nos procédés la
nouvelle plateforme a été fondé afin
d'améliorer la confiance ils allaient
pose toutes ces mesures fonctionnaires
aujourd'hui le document devient ce temps
documents clés pour améliorer la
prévisibilité des activités de tous les
états membres et tous les états
fonctionne pour ainsi assurer les mises
à jour de ce document et y répondre au
défi militaire actuelle parce que nous
avons un système de reporting qui
augmente entre aussi les capacités de
notre centre en plus les technologies
puissent appuyer les mesures de
supervision c'est ce que me fusent on
n'a par l'intermédiaire de caméras dès
cette année c'est ce que l'on aurait les
ont déjà comme l'usure à méteren
les armes nucléaires ce n'est pas un
concept nouveau parce qu'il ya un autre
de nouvelles formes d'armes comme les
cyber armes pour cette raison et il faut
continuer le dialogue
la réduction des risques la transparence
ce sont les éléments clés pour améliorer
la sécurité et pour que ces outils
restent d'actualité il faut qu'il soit
utilisé en permanence est mise à jour
chaque fois que les tensions on remonte
nous devrons suivre des procédures
établies sur tout et utiliser tous les
outils visant à améliorer la confiance
parce qu'au final nous allons tous
gagnés si la sécurité s'améliore ce pour
cette raison je m'adresse et j'appelle
tous les états à participer à notre
plateforme d'inclusion afin d'assurer la
compréhension mutuelle surtout sur le
plan de renforcement de confiance
n'avons pas d'entraînement nous n'avons
pas le temps que nous pouvons nous
permettre de perdre merci beaucoup de
votre attention
merci beaucoup madame schmidt
c'est tout à fait vrai que le est ce la
seule organisation ou d'entretien
quelques dialogues entre les militaires
et les phénomènes comme les changent
d'opinion sur les doctrines un dialogue
structuré mais il faut que ce dialogue
n'est pas de couleur politique il faut
qu'ils favorisaient la désescalade
c'est très bien vous
le fait que vous avez souligné
l'importance de ce s'est approchée en
plus la fédération de russie a déjà
proposé des mesures concrètes et dans le
cade allocution notre ministre de la
défense russe vous avez entendu qu'il
faut retirer les forces de neuf
frontières nationales mais pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas pu entendre
une réponse est positive constructive
un autre proposition merci beaucoup
maintenant d'après l'agenda j'aimerais
passer la parole à monsieur grouchko
l'adjoint au ministre des affaires
étrangères de la fédération de russie
qui vraiment ses propres s'est
approfondie dans les problèmes de la
sécurité européenne
merci beaucoup tout d'abord j'aimerais
saluer chers participants à cette
conférence
parce que les dialogues dans les
conditions actuelles est extrêmement
nécessaire et la conférence de moscou 7
jours car these par une analyse
détaillée de ce qui se passe dans le
monde entier
moi je vais me permettre de donner un
petit peu notre analyse de ce qui se
passe sur cet axe ils réagir à quelques
idées que le secrétaire général de l'est
ce cher helga schmidt est bien de
partager c'est tout à fait vrai que les
tendances sur le plan de la défense
européenne sont tristes parce que les
tensions augmentent les mécanismes
existants sont de fait des truites et en
plus l'escaladent augmente on parlait
beaucoup
hier et non partenaires et nos collègues
occidentaux on n'aborde pas ce sujet
parce que les relations entre nous et le
bloc occidental se trouveront une lionne
niveau le moment bas possible
la coopération s'est arrêté il ya plus
de voies de coopération entre les
militaires
la coopération avec l'union européenne
grâce au lobby anti russe aspire vers le
zéro il va aujourd'hui la plateforme de
laisser plutôt que les ecomotive de
confrontation à part mon nid au sein de
l'otan ni au sein de l'union européenne
on ne veulent pas accepter le fait que
nous sommes des oiseaux géographique qui
ont des liens culturels commerciaux
historique et malgré des oppositions
quand même un jour ou l'autre le nous
faudra chercher trouver tous ensemble
les réponses aux défis aux problèmes qui
menacent la prospérité de nos citoyens
nous sommes prêt à normaliser nos
relations avec des structures
européennes sur la base du respect
mutuel des intérêts et l'égalité en
droits parce que j'aimerais rappeler
encore une fois le fait que c'est pas du
tout la russie avait initié les pattes
qui permettent pas d'assurer une bonne
coopération au moins sur le plan de la
sécurité bilatéral en plus l'histoire
démontre beaucoup d'exemples comme par
exemple la lutte contre le terrorisme
international le piratage
la formation des cadres dans la lutte
contre le trafic et les gars des drogués
ou les potentiels et christie de russes
de l'europe et de l'automne donnait un
effet significatif seulement pour
assurer la sécurité des états mais aussi
de leurs situait à ce qui est de mon
devient de plus en plus revendiquer en
plus
jusqu'à présent il nous avons des
documents signés par nous mêmes les deux
qui m'ont les états européens états unis
qui pourrait servir de la base
je parle de la charte de paris pour la
nouvelle europe
la déclaration
du sommet d'istanbul de 1997 la base de
la convention de 1997 entre la russie de
l'automne qui contiennent les principes
de compréhension mutuelle
dix ans a évité les lignes de division
qui permettent à tous les pays de
participer à ce dialogue qui a juste sur
le plan de la sécurité it qui confirma
encore une fois le principe que la
sécurité de chacun c'est la sécurité de
tout le monde mais les spécificités de
l'étape actuelle réside en fait que nos
collègues occidentaux refusent
d'accepter cette phase i -p
évidemment cette situation est explosive
et même si les partis restent
raisonnables les incidents non
intentionnelle ne sommes pas exclu
qu'ils puissent ces résultats en conflit
réel et gr nous avons vu un incident
intentionnel qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences les plus graves possible
surtout du point de vue de les escalades
des actions qui peuvent résulter
vraiment conséquence complètement
imprévisible en plus ce qui nous
inquiète beaucoup cela le fait que le
temps de continuer à élargir sa présence
autour d'une frontière et augmente le
nombre de patrouilles mêmes et leur
bâtiment commence à partir dans la merde
une barre en scène et baltiques et parce
que ici on regarde la mer baltique il ya
on n'a jamais eu de problème depuis
longtemps et maintenant on voit que la
région de la mer noire se transforme en
arène d'opposition militaires tout à
fait non nécessaires pour cette raison
toutes ces actions de nos partenaires
occidentaux mettent ce péril et la
nécessité de lacs des basiques de la
convention entre la russie et l'otan de
en plus il faut parler de dieu problème
que la différence de la rotation
permanente par rapport à la présence
permanente des troupes de l'otan'' ici
on se fixe comme objectif d'assurer la
supériorité militaire on nous propose de
mettre à jour le document de vienne
ce qui ne fait que légitimiser six
niveaux élevés de présence de l'otan'' à
côté des frontières russes est et
l'activité intense et pieds de l'otan''
et dans ce comté que j'aimerais faire un
petit aparté entre parenthèses par
rapport à ce que madame schmidt alliés
ne devons oublier que le contrôler des
systèmes d'armes y compris les confiance
visant à améliorer la compréhension ne
devront pas être entreprise sans lien
avec une approche politique parce que
c'est toujours l'été le continent où les
guerres dévastatrices mondiale ont
commencé qui est devenu le centre
d'opposition entre les deux centres
surtout à l'époque de la guerre froide
et surtout sa cause grâce aux systèmes
d'armes et la construction du système de
la sécurité collective a généré ce
mécanisme de contrôle des systèmes
d'armes parce que sa mécanique de
contrôle d'armes de fait c'est le
contrôle de la sécurité par un petit lot
des moyens j'aimerais citer les
sceptiques qui nous ont permis de
comprendre qu'il vaut mieux éviter la
guerre froide et
speech est plutôt vers une vraie si tu
retiens collectif parce qu'il s'agit
tout d'abord du traité inf
le traité sur le ciel vers le traité sur
les forces conventionnelles en europe
mais aujourd'hui à cause des actions des
états unis ces trois documents ont perdu
leur valeur parce que de fait les états
unis ont interdit à ses alliés européens
de ratifier ces documents aujourd'hui on
ne pourrait plus se poser qu'est
l'action stabilisation ce contrat
pourrait avoir 6 l'éviter entrée en
vigueur en complément aux accords du
sommet de 1197 d'istambul y compris
aussi le code de comportement des états
dans le domaine de la sécurité qui est
aussi un état fondamental qui contient
une disposition qui prévoit que en
assurant la liberté de choix
les états doivent prendre en
considération les intérêts de la
sécurité des autres états ensuite les
charges globales de l'information
militaires les mesures de stabilisation
en cas d'urgence en cas de crise et si
nous regardons le document de vienne
nous pourrions comprendre que beaucoup
de choses de ce document ont été écrits
avec le ska randonnée ceux ayant de vie
qui par le sang parce qu'il prône de
bons chevaux afin de trouver de bonnes
solutions
la panification dans le domaine de la
défense et les principes de passage d
systèmes d'armes conventionnelles et qui
sont donc plutôt oublié par nos
partenaires
si on parle du soutien que les pays de
l'otan exerce au profit des pauvres ou à
kiev et un autre document conçoit des
armes légères et les armes à feu
évidemment aujourd'hui nous nous n'avons
plus de conditions il n'y a pas de
projet pour les six qui pourrait réunir
mme tous dans la convention du point de
vue de la des buses mandat nécessité
parce que l'état n'a fait encore son
cycle historique après la guerre froide
parce que nous avons vu la période des
portes ouvertes ensuite nous avons vu
une période des grands intervention lazy
goose la vie la libye à l'afghanistan
dont les conséquences ont clairement
connues pour tout le monde est de fait
est revenu à l'origine et à la raison de
sa mise en place ce qui était encore
formulé à l'époque diffère la dissuasion
de l'europe mais si on remplace
l'allemagne par l'union européenne on
peut voir que vu commencer à réaliser en
pratique au niveau le document de
l'alliance
cette formule est toujours en vigueur
est de fait c'est une sorte de
philosophie de la tentation de l'union
dans les conditions contemporaine je
dirais que peut-être on est nombreux à
croire que la dernière déclaration des
pays membres de l'otan
bon on a mentionné la russie les 63 fois
ci on en rêve tous ces paragraphes de
cette déclaration il en reste pas grand
chose parce que ça ne démontre que la
mission
elle que se posent l'alliance dans le
domaine de la fob assurer la sécurité
on n'y voit rien sauf les alinéas
consacrée à la russie
parfois on parle aussi de la chine et
qui est considérée comme opposant
stratégique aux états unis comme l'a dit
landes et ancien haut fonctionnaire de
l'alliance la russie est proche la chine
est loin
c'est pourquoi la menace aux deux russes
doit rester à la raison d'être de la
lance nous voyons que les pays membres
de l'otan ont pris la décision de
déployer de nouveau concept stratégique
si tous ces concepts philosophiques qui
ont été complétés dans le dernier
document tu seront mises en conseil
stratégique nos nous allons témoigné le
contexte sécuritaire européen qui jure
semblera de près celui de la guerre
froide que nous avons tous essayé
d'éviter la même démarche similaire est
démontré dans nos relations avec l'union
européenne nous avons entrepris des
tentatives parfois efficace de dynamiser
notre coopération
en organisant le dialogue politique et
en démontrant les capacités d'agir
ensemble sur différents théâtres dans la
fédération de russie à la demande de
l'union européenne et des aidés par les
hélicoptères les opérations au tchad et
à la rue blix la république
centrafricaine nous avons à proposer à
l'union europénne à de signer un accord
visant la coordination dans le domaine
de la gestion des crises
nul n'a profité des dialogues assez
structuré efficace au niveau militaire
nos policiers ont participé des
opérations monde tepr le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu en bosnie herzégovine
voilà c'est ce exemple prouve que
lorsque nous avons la compréhension
rationnelle de ce qu'il faut faire
ensemble et si nous mettons à côté les
approches à politiser la coopération
devient possible
efficace et plaisir les ira bleus
actuellement presque tout le massif
entre la russie et l'union européenne
tout est réduit à les exiger de l'est
russie le respect des accords de minsk
comme quoi la clé de la porte qui
ouvrira les relations entre bruxelles et
moscou
cette clé est offerte à le cren qu'ils
ne se pas ouvrir cette porte encore en
point ayant une importance
extraordinaire lorsque les lignes de
contact d
les exercices militaires se déplace pour
s'approcher des frontières et russe
les exercices militaires sont organisées
dans les régions qui n'ont pas été plus
haut auparavant s'affaireront pour les
contacts militaires de coopérations
on essaie de trouver des moyens en 2h
publiera cette escalade à trouver des
mécanismes de prévention des incidents
militaires dangereux mais avec tout mon
respect aux ambassadeurs je pense que
c'est que c'est pas à eux de discuter la
distance à sécuriser de rapprochement
entre les bâtiments de guerre c'est la
sphère des militaires de les discuter
mais malheureusement souvent les
politiques croient que l'idée même de
faire coopérer les militaires c'est
quelque chose d'interdît
alors je veux souligner ce que ce mythe
a déjà mentionné
c'était un contenu toutes les
restrictions politiques de jeu vers de
parler ce forum reste une heure
plateforme pour on cherche des solutions
à des problèmes nous d'opportunités même
si on n'arrive pas à trouver des pôles
et à organiser des plateformes on pourra
pour signer de nouveaux accords
l'essentiel était d'éviter la
dégradation ultérieure de la situation
et la participation des militaires dans
ces noeuds dans ces échanges la pratique
de d'information mutuel à la pratique
d'organisation de ce forum international
sur la sécurité internationale
la pratique dans four mais elle est
partie intéressée cyr la réalisation à
la planification des exercices
militaires doit être soutenu encouragé
parce que actuellement malheureusement
les pas positifs dans le domaine
militaire de coopération ne sont pas
nombreux il faut faire tout le
nécessaire tous les possibles pour l été
en fin de compte n'a la dégradation
actuelle qui risque de générer de
nouveaux qu'ils nouvelle crise au
continent européen sur dans le domaine
de la construction des forces armées et
nous voyons que c'est justement là où le
temps devient de plus en plus agressif à
la base d'une de l'analyse comment des
défis et des menaces modernes
nous nous devons essayer vidéo dresser
les lignes de comportement des règles de
comportement qui permettrait d'exclure
des accidents pareils à celui qui nous
avons témoigné hier avec le destroyer
britannique est l essentiel de ces deux
registres et la coopération dans de
nombreux domaines
sans cet argent de la positive entre les
militaires de tous les pays entre les
militaires de tous les états de l'europe
on n'arrivera pas à changer la donne je
vous remercie chaque collègue et moi si
je devais dormir si aller s'abriter
ritchie on a du mal à ne pas accepter
vos paroles sur la nécessité de dialogue
en treillis militaire
je vous remercie d'avoir a mentionné en
une grande quantité de documents qui
sont adoptés à autour du document de
vienne et qui doivent être respectées
maintenant j'ai passé parole vis
premier ministre de serbie monsieur
stepanovic c'est un politicien avec une
expérience d'une vingtaine d'années il
est l'un des députés du parlement et il
exerce sa fonction de quelle année
passée mesdames et messieurs
avant tout je tiens à remercier le
ministère de la défense
il faisait aussi je suis gosse je vous
remercie pour cette opportunité de
participer au sommet d'aujourd'hui c'est
un grand honneur de pouvoir aujourd'hui
de travailler avec vous la conférence de
moscou c'est une opportunité je dormirai
le dialogue et de procéder à l' échange
des opinions sur des questions de la
politique et menace militaire actuelle
au contexte de défis modernes
aujourd'hui aucun moi en tant que
ministre de la défense de l'une des
idées belkin un g7 tâche est donc de
parler des mesures visant à renforcer la
confiance dans notre région
d'après notre situation géographique et
des balkans sont toujours l'occident
pour le riom et le rien pour l'occident
ce que conditions en fait le passage de
germer à travers notre territoire de
cuques depuis des siècles passés
ce qui a laissé de nombreux problèmes
moi sécuritaire et des conflits gelés
qui n'ont pas encore trouvé leur réponse
est les conflits dans notre région on
était souvent en citer deux
l'extérieur à part des grandes
puissances et durant toute notre
histoire les balkans étaient plus
souvent objets et non pas le sujet des
relations internationales
nous en tant que société multiculturelle
avec un grande diversité ethnique et ce
que représente du côté notre richesse et
d'autre part en défi à supporter souvent
les balkans au lieu d'être des ponts de
coopération
devenez des points de conflits et de
confrontation la situation compliquée
dans le domaine à politique et
sécuritaire pour certains pays des
balkans les questions ethniques des
problèmes éthiques irrésolu un pèsent
sur la stabilité de la région
aujourd'hui le monde confronté robes et
des signes sécuritaire qui a ramené le
tableau devant deviennent de plus en
plus globaux en commençant par le
terrorisme et allant jusqu'à menacer
cybernétique et les criminels étaient
organisées ce qui croivent qui se croit
être apte à les supporter seuls ont tort
ah parce que il le faut des efforts
comment et le dialogue la république de
serbie et le terminer pour le dialogue
postiers de ce qu'on appelle kosovo nous
appliquons des efforts visant à
normaliser les relations et donc
protéger la population serbe et et nos
valeurs sacrées à kosovo et métaux qui
c'est un profiteur de l'occasion
j'aimerais remercier un conte fois la
russie dont le soutien nous avons
toujours senti surtout dans nos
exigences de respecter la souveraineté
et l'intégrité territoriale de la serbie
parce que le peuple serbe ne l'oublient
pas j'aimerais vous remercier deux fond
de mon coeur
la serbe est dorénavant on va toujours
agir pour en respect consécutif
est stricte et des dispositions du droit
international et de la résolution 12h44
du conseil de sécurité de l'organisation
des nations unies et la violation du
droit international à part la communauté
internationale et la violation de notre
souveraineté c'est juste un des exemples
d'absence de dialogue qui a résulté en
conséquence comme une fausse objets qui
a paru dans notre région et qui
représente une source de menace pour
toute la sécurité de toute l'europe mais
aussi une grande source d'instabilité
sur les balkans occidentaux nous
actuellement les pays qui financent
qu'on appelle la soi-disant fille
indépendant de kosovo ne discute même
plus du fait que le kosovo sert de la
base du trafic illégal d'espèces biais
stupéfiants aussi bien que l'exportateur
de l'extrémisme radicalisé au coeur de
l'europe
actuellement c'est un endroit on n'y a
pas de vie normale pour lui l bon qu'aux
de kosovo sans parler des problèmes des
serbes et du reste de la population
parce que elle la réponse à la question
aussi les balkans occidentaux vont
devenir un tonneau de poudre ou oasis de
paix dans les périodes futures va
dépendre confiture de plusieurs facteurs
n'est bien sûr ça va dépendre du
dialogue multilatéral sincère de jouer
acteurs le mulet internationaux la
serbie déterminé d'agir le garant les
planteurs de thé stabilité dans cette
partie du monde ne nous voulons pas
avoir de nouveaux conflits et j'aimerais
remarquer que la pelouse l'approchent
matière elle entend que et des
principales de la politique européenne a
démontré certaines faiblesses ressent
dans les frontières de l'union
européenne et par rapport aux autres
zones gestion d'intention
ce qui est vraiment devenu remarquer le
pendant à la lutte contre la pandémie de
la commune 19 c'est très bien le fait
que l'union européenne a identifié ces
problèmes et a commencé à changer les
mécanismes de réaction à ces crises en
construisons une nouveau système de
sécurité plus solide a parmi les états
membres
en même temps il a montré qu'il est
l'union européenne est capable d'inclure
d'autres pays en tant que est un
candidat et d'autres pays non candidats
pour qu'ils puissent faire leur
contribution au renforcement de la
sécurité en europe
j'aimerais rappeler un coin fois que les
états membres de l'union européenne sont
de vrais partisans pour sauvegarder la
paix par la voix de participation aux
différentes opérations multinationales à
travers le monde entier
houle a servi je joue un des rôles les
plus importants parce que nous
considérons que pour que la sécurité
construite en dehors des frontières
européennes est extrêmement importante
pour contrôler la sécurité en europe
elle le niveau supérieur du
professionnel et l'adhérence des
militaires des forces armées serbes dans
ces missions ont été reconnus et
hautement apprécié par tous les pays
avec il nous avons été impliqués
participer nous sommes toujours adhérent
des vrais partisans
au niveau de la coopération au sein de
l'union européenne pour cette raison
nous participons au développement de ces
mécanismes dans l'élaboration de
nouveaux mécanismes de sécurité en
commençant par les mécanismes de
protection civile où nous avons une
coopération au même niveau élevé avec
nos amis de russie j'ai même pas même
pas plus obligé de vous rappeler
question nous avons reçu l'ordre
fondation que notre pays a subi 2014
jusqu'à présent où nos pays commencent à
produire en commun leur accent soutenu
cuvée sur le site de l'institut serbe
tornac chers amis chers collègues et la
tronche multilatéral par rapport à la
résolution des problèmes et se base sur
la compréhension mutuelle et le respect
des normes internationales
sr et représente le seul chemin
tous visent à renforcer la sécurité dans
la région des balkans occidentaux
pour cette raison nous apprécions la
position des principes forts de la
fédération de russie et le respect de
son côté un des principes de résolution
de la sécurité des filles et des balkans
occidentaux sur la base des normes
occidentales et sous l'égide et des
formats multilatéraux et dans les
conditions de mon pied de la suffisance
que l'échec est différente forme à notre
latéraux par rapport aux balkans
occidentaux et la lenteur de
l'intégration européenne les initiatives
régionales acquiert de plus en plus
d'importance aujourd'hui même s'ils sont
pas décisives et sont extrêmement
importantes
donc elle est république et serbat à un
vrai intérêt fort et concret sur dix ans
à mettre en place des mécanismes
régionaux pour prévenir les risques et
les menaces ce qu'il est et bien
démontré un pratiquant dans la recherche
des réponses optimum aux défis créés
les résultats de la pandémie de kobe 19
permettez-moi de vous rappeler qu'entre
autres et que nous avons aidé pendant la
vaccination dans plusieurs pays parmi
nos collègues étrangères en plus la
coopération multilatérale ou la serbie
essaie de montrer l'importance
concernant l'amélioration de la
compréhension de ce qui se passe la
compression de la région repose un
intérêt commun plus est les divergences
et les gentils j'ai les problèmes ne
peuvent être résolus 4 avait à la
coopération
tu basé sur la bonne volonté de
s'adresser aux futures commandes par
l'intermédiaire d'un dialogue
multilatéral
on ne peut que atteindre la
compréhension d'une gamme plus large de
besoins des intérêts et donc réduire les
possibilités des compréhensions
exclusive des extrêmes en plus il s'agit
de respect complet et non est sélectif
parce que ça commençait et devient un
facteur clé pour l'autorité des états et
préserver la confiance
mesdames et messieurs la pandémie de
grippe 19 nous indiquait encore une fois
que nous sommes obligés de changer et de
remplacer les tendances et d'approchés
unis partie de fragmentation de
confrontation par la solidarité et le
respect mutuel et donc renforcer les
formats multilatéraux existantes
tout d'abord lé sous l'égide de l'onu et
de l'aiea sur ce qu'il s'agit de du
renforcement de vrai dialogue sincère et
partenariat basé sur les principes et le
base est égal parce que ça devient
impérative pour atteindre la paix la
stabilité la prospérité
merci beaucoup de votre attention
je veux remercier monsieur le ministre
pour votre analyse de situation balkans
le rôle de la serbie est unique il n'est
pas à sous-estimer comme sans que sa
contribution a juré à la sécurité
européenne je remercie et je tiens à
demander des panélistes vais respecter
les durées d'intervention maintenant je
passais pas voir le monsieur guillaume
burger directeur du département de
coopération bilatérale de la direction
générale de quoi des relations
internationales de la stratégie du
ministère de de la défense de l'armée
française et monsieur legrand professeur
en histoire est l'auteur de nombreux
ouvrages pour l'histoire internationale
alors bon c'est mon intervention puisque
nous sommes à moscou en rappelant un mot
célèbre de votre grand écrivain tolstoï
qui disait au début d'un à karénine que
toutes les familles heureuses se
ressemblent mais que les familles
malheureuses leçon chacune à leur façon
alors je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
position en tout cas de la france la
famille européenne est malheureuse et ce
malheur pour nous vient de trois raisons
principales
d'abord la première raison on en a
beaucoup parlé depuis deux jours c'est
la menace terroriste
le terrorisme djihadiste continue de
sévir dans beaucoup de parties du monde
et en particulier dans l'environnement
régional de l'europe que ce soit au
moyen-orient où que ce soit en afrique
donc ça c'est la première raison qui
continuent de peser
la deuxième raison on en a aussi
beaucoup parlé
c'est la multiplication des menaces
militaires qui sont anciennes mais qui
ont tendance à se multiplier
alors je pense évidemment
au cyber à l'espace mais dans le
voisinage immédiat de l'europe il y à la
prolifération des armes de destruction
massive on l'a vu utilisé dans le
conflit en syrie il y à la prolifération
des armes nucléaires
vous avez cité le cas de l'iran
donc toutes ces menaces sont
préoccupantes pour la sécurité
européenne et enfin dernière raison dans
sur le territoire même de l'europe les
zones de conflit en tendance à se
multiplier
on a cité les balkans juste avant
aujourd'hui du caucase le haut karabagh
la géorgie jusqu en allant vers l'ouest
à la moldavie en passant par l'ukraine
on a un ensemble de conflit qui nous
préoccupe beaucoup
et du point de vue de la france ces
conflits doivent se régler dans le
respect du droit international
sous la supervision de l'onu et je vous
rappelle que le droit international
c'est la souveraineté des états et le
respect des frontières
internationalement reconnues
alors face à ces trois problèmes
quelles sont les solutions de la france
la france elle considère qu'il y à trois
voies de sortie trois solutions à ces
problèmes la première solution c'est de
maintenir le cadre de droit
international qui a jusqu'ici permis de
régler beaucoup de problèmes dans le
droit international
il y à des traités alors on a beaucoup
parlé depuis deux jours de la fin d'un
certain nombre de traités de désarmement
en europe la fin du traité sur les
forces nucléaires intermédiaires et bien
de ce point de vue là nous regrettons
que des mécanismes éprouver le traité
sur les forces conventionnelles en
europe
le traité ciel ouvert ne soient plus
respectés par leurs signataires donc les
états unis et maintenant la russie donc
ce qui nous préoccupe nous français
c'est que il faut maintenir ce qui peut
être maintenue alors de ce point de vue
là nous nous réjouissons qu'un accord
ait pu être trouvé en matière de
désarmement nucléaire sur le traité new
start
nous espérons que d'autres voie
conventionnelle pourront permettre la
modernisation d'autres traités je pense
par exemple au document de vienne que
nous avons incité tout à l'heure ça
c'est premier axe le deuxième axe de
notre de ses solutions la deuxième
solution
ces deux d'accroître la coopération
internationale alors la coopération
internationale elle passe pour la france
en parle autant qui est une alliance
défensive je le rappelle elle passe
aussi par l'union européenne dans le
développement de la défense européenne
et enfin elle peut passer par des
coopérations entre états qui soit hors
de ces organisations
vous savez que la france s'est beaucoup
engagée en afrique aux côtés des états
africains dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
nous avons lancé une nouvelle opération
basée sur les forces spéciales qui
s'appelle l'opération takouba et cette
opération est intéressante puisqu'elle
va mobiliser des pays européens des pays
qui sont dans l'union européenne ou des
pays qui qui n'y sont pas par exemple la
serbie 1 va participer à l'opération
takouba donc ça c'est le deuxième
le deuxième axe pour sécuriser
environnement européen et puis enfin le
troisième axe la troisième solution
c'est le dialogue et je pense de ce
point de vue là le dialogue avec la
russie
je reviendrai pas sur le rôle que la
russie joue un je crois que depuis deux
jours on a vu qu'elle était un état très
important dans la sécurité
internationales
dont vous savez que depuis 2010 9 depuis
deux ans le président français macron a
rappelé un dialogue entre la france et
la russie
l'objectif étant de construire une
nouvelle architecture de sécurité en
europe
ce dialogue s'est traduit par un certain
nombre de deux corbeilles de il ya cinq
corbeille de discussion il ya également
un ensemble de groupes de travail puis
le 10 groupes de travail qui ont été qui
ont été constitués
l'objectif c'est de multiplier les
rencontres pour trouver des solutions à
ces problèmes communs alors d'ores et
déjà on a eu un certain nombre de
progrès je pense notamment au fait que
des militaires français le chef d'état
major français est venue en russie
rencontrer son homologue en 2020
aujourd'hui la crise sanitaire a ralenti
ces discussions et puis elles ont été
ralenties aussi il faut bien le dire par
l'impression qu'il n'y avait pas
suffisamment de progrès dans l'est dans
les discussions
donc ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui je
crois que notre venue à moscou en est le
symbole
c'est d'appeler à plus d'engagement avec
la russie nous avons nous français pris
position pour que dans le cadre de
l'otan soit organisé un nouveau conseil
otan russie
nous nous réjouissons de la rencontre
entre le président américain et le
président poutine qui va dans le sens de
ce que nous de ce que nous souhaitions
et nous espérons que ce type de
rencontre qui va se multiplier pourra
permettre de résoudre les problèmes qui
se posent à la sécurité européenne
voilà je vous remercie
je remercie monsieur lagarde pour les
solutions proposées par la france
juste je vais donner en commentaire de
ma part personnelle je dois dire que les
vecteurs de dialogue qui venait de
mentionner l'afrique et le respect des
engagements internationaux dialogue
entre la russie l'union européenne et
les pays européennes à l'heure tous ces
sujets font partie de l'agenda de notre
conférence
n'est ce pas une conscience des opinions
qui mérite d'être souligné maintenant je
vois quatre rôles au monsieur peeters
vac chercheurs de l'institut mme merkel
nick foran observatoire de wilson
monsieur vaquer s'étant militaire de
carrière à une général des brigades en
retraite
il a beaucoup travaillé en russie en
tant qu'attaché militaire et pendant sa
fonction en russie il était responsable
pour le développement de la coopération
entre les forces armées des états unis
et le ferait armée de la fédération dire
ici alors ces insulines sa grande
expérience dans le domaine qui nous
intéresse monsieur bac avoue le père
rôle qui lui plaît
ah ah
bonjour bonjour je tiens à remercier les
hôtes de la conférence les organisateurs
pour l' envie d'action qui précède je
veux partager mon opinion sur la
sécurité européenne
c'est ça c'est tendance et ses
perspectives que moi je vais en te
revenir en tant que personne privée 100
en tant que citoyen un américain et non
pas en tant que fonctionnaire ou en tant
que chercheur mes observations
concernent plutôt les russies mais j'ai
pensé que l'on donne l'opportunité pour
l'audience
nous voilà en conférence - une semaine
après le sommet de genève
ce qui est très intéressant c 'est pas
les différends qui manquait avant
d'entrer dans cet entretien
mais ils ont su organiser cette
rencontre est on sûr ghinzu dialogue
ouvert et transparent c'est l'exemple
second succès les présidents ont su
tombés d'accord sur des aspects
importants
c'est le temps qui nous prouvera six
semaines à 1 favorisera l'amélioration
des relations bilatérales pas mais le
fait même de la tenue de ce sommet est
déjà encourageant j'ai 32 ans
d'expérience en tant le veto russe
trente deux ans je travaille avec les
russes a commencé en 1901 à 99
hors des clans de la guerre froide
lorsque j'ai reçu le visa de l'union
soviétique rouge eu de la chance vous le
saurez dans la ville de kalinine qui a
timidement avec ou sans nom de terre où
j'ai appris la langue russe
j'adore là aussi sa culture j'ai de
nombreux amis rue ce que j'aime beaucoup
alors qu'à mangakas revanche je le vends
2 jean 1941 le conflit de ce désastreux
de l'histoire moderne a commencé à
bondir pas que thil qu'elle a commencé
le vent de genre lorsque les troupes
allemandes ont attaqué le pays
c'est pas le faire que c'est une
commémoration
moi j'ai fait j'ai été en russie en 1991
lorsque le pillage commémorer les 50 ans
de la guerre
je me souviens au ses anciens
combattants couvert de médailles et
décorations il faut jamais oublier ce
temps de guerre alors sur trois pays ont
su s'unir et de venir à lier toutes les
15 et république et au sens de l'union
soviétique ont combattu durant cette
guerre ensemble avec les alliés
moi j'étais la tâche est née des ter
entre 2014 et j'ai eu cet honneur de
piles assisté pendant des événements
différents aspects des rejouera qu
est-ce qu à volgograd
moi aussi j'étais à moscou leur de
soixante dixième anniversaire de la
victoire nonobstant tout est différent
on trouve dans nos positions on a su
travailler ensemble durant la guerre
pour notre victoire commune
je pense c'est le temps de faire encore
une fois pour résoudre les problèmes de
portes unités c'est pour ça que je suis
là c'est pour ça que j'interviens de
donges où l'europe est préoccupé
l'europe est différente de l'europe de
demain midi les années 40 ou ceux du
début du siècle en 1914 et en 1939
l'europe a été bouleversé par des
conflits
on a su surmonter ses ex guerre qu'il
mène à celle attendue l'humanité
aujourd'hui nous avons entre ne m'en
larmes encore le fils en plus
désastreuse
tout devient plus dangereux mettant on
utilise les technologies cybernétiques
et ce qui rend la situation encore plus
dangereuse encore le délétère
nous assistons à une concurrence entre
les puissances
quand c'est thierry valette et prendra
forme quand est ce que cette menace sera
réalisé et se répondre à ça partout en
tout à tous et à toutes les directions
il est très important de prendre des
décisions communes en dialoguant grâce
sodium a su prolonger le traité start
pour les cinq ans au futur peut-être
pour nous c'est la dernière possibilité
d'approcher les questions clé de la
stabilité de la stabilité stratégique
les deux présidents en s'accepter on
peut assumer ses nouvelles tâches et ont
commencé ont lancé ce dialogue visant à
trouver des solutions à renforcer la
confiance et la transparence des
relations nous avons su surmonter la
bière à froide
est-ce qu'on peut refaire c'est
explorables geab est les menaces sont
nouvelles
lancel et jean sassi fille ciel larmes
de haute précision de grande portée des
menaces cybernétiques
bon des puissances les états unis et la
russie
pourtant cette responsabilité du tout
faire comme il faut je peux être à
l'avenir on y trouvera le rôle pour la
gelée par la chine
si l'on avoir leur place ce n'est que le
futur qui tranchera sur s'inscrire à ces
propos je reviens au sujet des crimes à
cybernétique bon les 30 actions dans le
domaine cybernétique est peut-être
dirigé par l'état ou par des privés
c'est une honte
c'est le grand défi d'actualité et
président biden a très nettement dit ça
doivent d'être inacceptable pour tous
les états les criminels qui ont attaqué
coloniale patelin aux états unis
d'amérique en secte en leur système par
un virus ont généré une situation
dangereuse
du point de vue stratégique les
criminels ne doivent pas se sentir
libres pour agir
chez nous en russie et je vais poser
cette question lépi et entend un énorme
potentiel gourmande doivent-ils riposter
à des actes pareils surtout lorsqu'il
s'agit des deux sont sensibles d'entre
eux structures qui sont attaquées ce qui
génère une menace en danger de
destruction ou même de victimes
comment est-ce qu'on peut régir et
qu'est ce que nous devons ces ensembles
pour parer aux menaces nouvelles et les
terres parfois des incidents peuvent
touch peuvent être spontanée les pays
détenteurs des armes nucléaires
quelle sera leur réaction par exemple en
quête d'une crise nucléaire qui si sûr
j'irai à cause d'une attaque
cybernétique ayant touché des points
trop sensible moi j'étais toujours le
partisan de l'otage et je crois que nos
pouvons cohabiter coexister ensemble
avec les russies sentait stressé
champlain de calme le temps et l'union
européenne
est-ce que la russie et les autres pays
peuvent les considérer en ce temps qu'un
gage de stabilité en europe et non pas
comme une menace est en danger c'est la
même chose pour l'europe et les états
unis et leur vision de la russie le lap
est stable en europe
est ce que ça peut être positif à long
terme sur la russie notamment
vous comprenez la l'histoire mieux que
moi et mes que les autres goethe être
vous ne serez pas andreu à être tout à
fait d'accord avec mes propos mais
croyez moi est ce que vous pensez
vraiment que la russie serait plus
sécurisée dans le monde sent autant le
monde sent autant ce serait plus
sécurisé pour les rues si vous
connaissez cette sentence la nature ne
supporte pas le vide
le comble il faut créer une atmosphère
de confiance est important tout les
exercices militaires sujet des
informations préalables ça pourra
renforcer la coopération se fout de la
coopération non seulement entre les
leaders non seulement entre les capitaux
entre
les états-majors et tous car peut-être
même entre les postes de commandement
stratégique
c'est peut-être dépens de commandement
de nos alliés aussi mon leader militaire
comme les généraux des commandants elles
peuvent rencontrer les uns des autres
par exemple notre ministre de la défense
austin et votre ministre je suis ils
peuvent se rencontrer et parler
évidemment ce sera pas une conversation
simple et facile mais c'est boris
générer des conséquences positif en
rajoutant de l'oxygène en nos relations
et tout fait ce que nous permettra
d'atteindre le niveau de coopération que
nous avons connu il ya 20 ans il ya dix
ans c'était pas idéal c'est petit mais
c'était quelque chose là j'ai pas encore
terminé et on court quelques mois tout
juste
et le président a en avons parlé il faut
réduire la militarisation de l'arctique
aux victimes membres du conseil arctique
et doit continuer à céder médicalisation
il faut arrêter les violences en ukraine
ces violences doit se déplace un
dialogue est conforme aux accords de
minsk la coordination doivent être
incinérés pour barrer les menace des
changements climatiques dans le monde
entier surtout en fait concert l'extrême
heures ensuite les questions de
prolifération des armes de destruction
massive il faut les contrôler le
terrorisme alors les relations doivent
être guidés par la coopération et non
pas par la militarisation là mais
l'intervention par exemple de l'espace
nous les etats-unis et la russie sont
des deux puissances heures au smic c'est
avec une longue histoire de coopération
il faut pas saper cette histoire et
cette opération pour en suivant à c'est
la série et la situation doit être revue
une mer noire mais la méditerranée il
faut éviter toute source de conflits
régionaux la demande d'emi faut pas se
poser il faut coopérer lorsque les
amiraux l'équipe i qui alors nettement
les relations entre la russie et les
etats unis avec entre la russie et
l'europe
ces relations sont tendues je pense que
c'est notre solide bagage historique et
qui pèse sur nous et parfois à la
perception déformée des andes et hop
s'ils n'ont pas la réalité
c'est ça ce qui nous empêche et il faut
le rejeter je suis très content de
terminer quelques jours seulement après
la commémoration du début de la grande
guerre patriotique et je vous appelle à
vous rappeler de cette expérience
d'union de travail comment de
coopération pour la cause commune
il faut travailler ensemble avec les
alliés avec les amis et même avec le
concurrent pour créer un monde plus sûr
plus viable pour notre petit fils je
vous remercie de votre attention et
merci beaucoup mon général vous avez
fait part de nombreuses propositions de
nombreuses idées qui doit être analysée
surtout votre expert de très haut niveau
merci beaucoup d'avoir partager vos
réflexions là dessus et maintenant
j'aimerais passer la parole à la
finlande et s'il vous plaît un fichier
du rire est celle bonjean qu'une fois
qu'il est conseillé démission de la
défense de la réponse de fa landes qui
est à dieu j'ai beaucoup et de nombreux
dossiers dans le domaine de la sécurité
de la défense et messieurs raid sur
l'eau c'est à vous la parole merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs
tout d'abord j'aimerais remercier les
organisateurs de cette conférence de la
possibilité d'intervenir ici devant elle
de parler de la question en europe
concernant la sécurité
évidemment nous sommes en train de
réaliser pendant plusieurs décennies des
recherches concernant la sécurité
et j'aimerais j'aimerais faire part
d'une analyse brève de ce qui se passe
avec la sécurité du pont de l'europe
et après je pars courriel à propos de
plusieurs pourront que j'ai préparé
exprès dans le cas de ma présentation
surtout en parlant des sentences en
cours
tout d'abord en ce qui concerne la
sécurité en europe à la situation
générale s'est aggravée depuis la
dernière des saignées les tensions
militaires se sont aggravées et
aujourd'hui malheureusement nous voyons
pas de nous voyons plus de lumière au
bout du tunnel
en plus de nouvelles technologies
rajoute du nouveau carter ham dynamique
en plus la numérisation d'autres
technologies en développement nous donne
de nouvelles possibilités mais en même
temps elles représentent de nouveaux
défis pour la société c'est qu'ils
puissent avoir un impact sur le
fonctionnement de l'infrastructure est
un peu ces pisse déstabiliser l'équipe
libre de force parce que les sphères des
activités mettez vous élargir mais
voyons d'une façon évidente dans le
cyberespace et dans d'autres domaines en
plus à la limite de démarquage des leurs
parmi et entre les technologies civiles
et militaires deviennent de plus en plus
un vécu comme entre les conflits la
compétition et la guerre je ne peux pas
dire que la situation n'est plus
contrôlée on peut rien faire pour
améliorer la situation je parle plutôt
tout d'abord du fait que les efforts
doivent être visées alléger les
conséquences négatives de la reddition
de la sécurité
améliorer la gestion à long terme
aujourd'hui les hauts fonctionnaires
d'état prenne la décision qui
définissent le futur quartier de la
sécurité bien sûr il existe des facteurs
de structures qui on n'a pas été sur la
prise de décision mais quand même ce
sont les gens qui font l'histoire et
même je suis pas dans les circonstances
dans lesquelles est parfois ça se passe
j'aimerais juste citer les trois points
les plus importants à mon avis du pont
de la sécurité en europe
tout d'abord en en premier lieu je ne
leur ai parlé de la diplomatie de la
deûle interaction avec d'autres amis
entre les adversaires parce que c'est
une chose extrêmement importante parce
que ce que nous voyons c'est le monde
qui est de sécurité dans ce domaine et
les tentatives de comprendre l'humain
les actions des autres dans le domaine
de sécurité
ah mais non des missions diplomatiques à
mon avis reste un des outils les plus
efficaces je pense que ce chemin quand
même là se réserve toujours un potentiel
que nous pourrions utiliser dans les
médias en plus j'aimerais citer d'autres
exemples par exemple les exemples qui
date de l'époque de la guerre froide au
losange a souligné le besoin de
l'interaction diplomatique mais ici
aussi imaginer des situations où les
acteurs principaux ne partage pas la
même compréhension
mais en même temps nous avons et nous
voyons plusieurs axes pour cette
interaction éventuels comme les
changements climatiques et la guerre la
lutte contre le terrorisme
ce sont les exemples que la diplomatie
pourrait discuter au niveau des experts
surtout pour favoriser au passage au
d'autres questions concernant la
sécurité européenne
j'aimerais parler du deuxième poids qui
concerne le contrôle des systèmes
d'armes parce qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
une situation particulière surtout les
situations qui fait partie de ce monde
est lié avec deux coffres facteurs comme
l'espace nouvelles technologies et cyber
espace sont les tous les facteurs qui
sont liés entre eux
pour cette raison nous devons assurer la
réponse est multi facettes et nous
rappelons que situation pourrait
s'aggraver très très vite
en plus il ne faut pas oublier des
outils qui vise à améliorer la
transparence et m aussi bien que la
confiance mutuellement sans oublier les
armements conventionnels parce que très
souvent les origines est en retard et
ils pendent auriez lieu à cause du
développement technologique rapide mais
cas mais nous devons respecter les
accords et traités existants sont les
négligences vont trouver les points de
consistance et converger nos actions
disant améliorer la compréhension
mutuelle et réduire les risques et nous
devons appliquer désaccord comment pour
échanger des informations
en plus sur le plan pratique
probablement on va atteindre de nouveaux
accords visent à à renforcer notre
sécurité globale universel et mon
troisième point est lié avec la
confiance et les mesures visent à
améliorer la confiance parce que ces
mesures doivent jouer un rôle plus
important surtout dans le monde
contemporain
surtout par rapport aux écrasements
militaires par exemple la thaïlande
notifie les autres acteurs de tous les
noms que nous sommes en train de
réaliser conformément au document
deviennent un truc conformité avec les
règles de lesseux en plus surtout de
lézat traitement qui se passe sur le
territoire en finlande pour cette raison
les mesures et les outils qui vise à
améliorer la confiance ont toujours
respecté même pendant la pandémie de
kobe 19 contenu toutes les limitations
existantes
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
merci beaucoup chers invités
merci beaucoup monsieur rizzello votre
estimation de helsinki est extrêmement
importante et c'est tout à fait vrai il
vaut mieux chercher en commun la lumière
au bout du tunnel est surtout par les
voiles diplomatique qui a en conclusion
permettez moi de passer la parole au
représentant permanent de la fédération
de russie auprès de l'union européenne
monsieur vladimir tchijov cher vadimir
qui étant vraiment un diplomate très
expérimenté qui connaît très bien
comment ça se passe sur ta frauciel
passé que c'est vous qui allez finaliser
notre panel merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup chez argué me si on parle de
l'estrie avantageuses ou non et c'est
vraiment est une question elle disputait
pas sécu surtout c'est le moment d'en
parler juste avant le déjeuner devons
les intervenants et de mecha mais je
suis ravi de la possibilité d'agir de
vous rejoindre même par un format en
direct j'ai même commencé par la chose
évidente depuis à la tenue de la
conférence précédente en avril 2019
le monde a changé nous avons vu de
nombreux événements de premier plan et
surtout la première place est occupée
par la pandémie de
l'infection de colo 19 qui perd 6
jusqu'à présent ikki résultats en
conséquence négative y ramène de
nouveaux risques écologiques économiques
et un impact et surtout tu la connais
tes mondiale et bien sûr le cerf a
flotté sur le système de la sécurité
internationale dans ce je pense pas que
ce serait nécessaire et raisonnable a de
discuter des sources ou d origine de
cette de ce virus qui à produire à quel
niveau qu'un vaccin je propose de
laisser à nos partenaires d'en discuter
je pense que l'essentiel réside un autre
chose
l'humanité a perdu la chance historique
pour réunir ses efforts comme ans pour
faire face à un ennemi commun qui est
pris qui n'a pas de privilège de
préférences politiques et sociaux sans
faire la différence entre les riches et
les pauvres les droite à la gauche les
partys ont des valeurs qualifiées neil
ou libérale essai c'est vraiment très
strictes actuellement il ya beaucoup de
personnes y compris des lecteurs de
niort open air est sûr que dès les
premiers jours de la pandémie ils ont
essayé de démontrer la solidarité comme
et non on se rappelle craignant qu'il
était la réaction à chaotique et surtout
2 7 millions dans l'intégration la plus
avancée surtout pendant les premiers six
mois de lutte contre la copie de 19
de fait à l'époque nous avons vu des
mesures extraordinaires nom qu'on
donnait au niveau national avec la
fermeture des frontières entre les états
de l'union européenne surtout en parlant
de l' union occidentale mais évidemment
ce serait ou pas non plus utile de
nier le fait qu'elle est évident le mot
à la crise qui est écrit en chinois de
deux mots donc lui dire à le danger
l'autre veut dire l'opportunité la
possibilité avec le danger ça c'est
clair maintenant il faut que cette crise
serve de la leçon pour la communauté
internationale au futur je ne veux pas
être considéré comme sinica en se
rappelant toutes les victimes qui
comptent presque 4 millions de personnes
non condoléances à leurs familles quand
même il faut rester conscient du fait
que nous sommes face à un virus dont le
taux de mortalité ne fait que 2 % parce
que l'histoire de l'humanité connaissez
des maladies infectieuses avec le taux
de mortalité supérieure à 10 même à 90%
on peut pas garantir que les virus et
les affections plus dangereuses vont
apparaître
mais nous devons y être prêt au cou
mieux par rapport à ce qui se constate
et à l'époque de l'apparition de qourna
virus deuxième chose nous voyons des
changements dans les liaisons
transatlantiques
las le gan lancé par joe biden a marqué
ce but s'est il a été accueilli avec
enthousiasme à part les alliés des
etats-unis au sein de l'europe et de
l'otan'' j'aimerais rappeler que les
deux unions regroupe à environ 28 états
mais comme ses partenaires qui sont se
faire de donald trump et qu'ils ne
considéraient pas nécessaire de réduire
la vie de son propre père était
exceptionnel sens parfois respecté de
bonnes manières
mais aujourd'hui ce que nous voyons nous
rappellent des événements
qui nous avons déjà constaté il ya 12
ans à l'époque et de la vague de faerie
et qui a eu le nom obama manille et
j'aimerais souligner que quand même le
le montant et le volume l'étendue de ses
émotions et plus petit parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de blessures qu'il faudra
guerrier mais quand même aujourd'hui
entre l'union européenne et les etats
unis
il ya des divergences qui reste sur le
plan commercial économique aussi bien
que sur la question stratégique comme
les relations avec la chine
parce que si on parle de la même chose
avec la russie vu qu'il faut faire
l'amitié avec mai mais par apple par
rapport aux relations avec la chine ce
n'est pas évident parce que pour la
première fois pour l'année précédente
lâché à devenir le partenaire pour le
chiffre d'affaires de 581 1 6 milliard
de dollars 1 dépassons avec les chiffres
d'affaires de 555 milliards de dollars
par rapport aux états unis eyal
bruxelles à ses propres intérêts qui
n'aimerait pas mettre sur la pierre et
les sacrifiés sur l'autel nos
démocraties parce qu'ils plus sans
parler du aurait forcé de l'afghanistan
aussi bien que de la politique de
protection et de la lutte sous tapis
dans la distribution des vaccins contre
le corps d'un virus alors qu'est ce que
c'est parce ce contexte concernant
l'autonomie stratégique d'éclairer peur
ob le peu que l'europe à a pu faire en
tant que acteurs indépendants et
neutralisé par son partenaire ya ce
soi-disant stratégique avec le temps
dans le cadre up nom de laquelle en
valise 74 propositions communes
concernant l'union des deux
organisations de grands plans militaire
de défense la majorité paie l'initiative
militaires européennes sont étroitement
liées avec les initiatives de l'otan
trois pays les états unis le canada et
la norvège ont eu l'accès aux projets
dans le cadre de coopérations permis
structurée permanente
la poursuite de cette tendance p nous a
muni à l'aggravation de la situation et
le renforcement de l'influencé
extérieure au secteur s'est refait en
l'intégration des structures est aussi
renforcée y compris dans le domaine des
menace hybride et et de potentiel
cybernétique à en pratiquer c'est le
processus qui vise à faire participer à
à la position à la russie des pays comme
le triche mal de suez des nains qui ne
font pas partie de le temps mais font
partie de l'union européenne
le dialogue bernadette belgrade et
pristina qui est dialogue de bosnie
herzégovine le
l'union européenne étant a déclaré le
leader du processus est prête à faire
partager son je dirais pas le succès
parce que le succès s'est pas encore là
l'union européenne est prête à partager
ses responsabilités en ce qui concerne
la turquie
bruxelles et washington recherche les
réponses en parallèle mais d'une façon
coordonnée il est le temps constaté que
la situation dans le domaine de la
sécurité européenne et subit une crise
profonde compter à ce que nos
partenaires europe occidentaux acceptent
les approches basées à l'égalité au
respect mutuel au principe de
souveraineté et refus de renforcement de
socialité de sévérité d'autres ont peu
pâle
on peut pas compter à cet effet mais ça
signifie pas que le travail de
conspiration doit être ajournée au
arrêté au contraire parce que sinon
c'est meilleur temps n'arriveront jamais
je veux remercier de votre attention
merci monsieur pigeon pour votre analyse
profonde
on a de quoi réfléchir chers collègues
c'est le temps de terminer notre travail
notre scission je crois qu'il a été
efficace
malheureusement nous n'avons pas de
temps pour les questions et les réponses
c'est le temps de déjeuner comme on dit
chez nous dans l'armée la guerre c'est
la guerre mais le déjeuner celle dé
gêner
ghost est obligée de la poudre rasta et
mesdames et messieurs vous êtes priés de
ne pas oublier de remettre les
récepteurs des de la production
simultanée les iphone